- Skin's very dry.
- I know.
- Did you moisturize it?
- Yes.
- Okay.
- It's very bumpy.
Hi, I'm Garrett.
- And I'm Niki.
- We're fascinated by
how other people live.
- [Niki] So we're gonna try and find some
really interesting living situations.
- [Garrett] And live there,
experiencing a totally
different lifestyle.
- [Niki] To see which ones
bring us closer together,
- [Garrett] Or push us further apart.
- This week, we're living in an RV.
- Why'd you emphasize it like that?
- I don't know.
- I drove it here.
- Hi, my name is David, and this is my RV.
It's a 32 foot, fits six
people very, very comfortably.
I've never had anybody take my RV out
and say, "We didn't have a good time."
It's usually an experience
that they didn't expect
and plan on doing so again in the future
because they had such a fun time.
- Hi.
- I'm David.
- I'm Niki, nice to meet you.
- You guys wanna take a look?
- Yeah please, let's do it.
- Come on in.
- We're spending three days in an RV
driving around Arizona.
- When you think of RV,
I think the destination you
think of is the Grand Canyon.
I think it's gonna be a perfect trip.
- If we're going somewhere,
I wanna get there efficiently and quickly.
RVs are all about taking your time,
taking the scenic route.
If we wanna go see the Grand Canyon,
let's just go see the Grand Canyon
and then fly the hell out of there.
- People live in these things.
My grandparents spent
months at a time in an RV.
- (sighs) I don't get it,
it's not efficient, inconvenient,
slow (laughs).
Oh, okay.
- What'd you think it was gonna be?
- [Niki] I don't know.
- Wow, look at this TV.
- Oh, there's a TV.
- And I fit, just right.
- Yeah, kind of.
- I think this is really
gonna put Garrett's size
to the test because
there's no space in this.
- I'm 6'7, people, we
gotta start living bigger.
I know everybody's trying to
downsize and stuff, stop it.
- Now, this is the slide.
We're gonna extend it right now.
- What?
- [Niki] Oh, no way.
This house is getting bigger.
- [Garrett] That's amazing.
- Obviously, there's not a
lot of room inside of it.
- There's only one actual bed,
but then I think a bunch of other places
fold out into beds, which is neat,
a lot of things that have dual purposes.
- You can eat over here.
This also turns into a bed.
This'll probably be where you're sleeping.
I did measure it.
It's eight feet across so you'll have
plenty of room up there.
- Yeah, oh my gosh, it's super long.
- [Niki] Wow, we were
so worried about you.
- It has a shower, bathroom.
I measured it, it is actually 6'10.
- [Garrett] Oh really, wow,
well that's gonna be great.
- [David] Come in here, I
wanna show you guys something.
Right here (toilet flushes)
- [Niki] That's it?
I can do that.
Have you had any toilet disasters?
- I have not.
- Has anyone else?
- They have not.
The kitchen is complete,
it's everything that you would
expect inside your kitchen.
You got a refrigerator and freezer here.
- [Niki] This is like a kitchen.
- It is absolutely a kitchen.
- What'd you think it was gonna be?
- We are in a car.
And it's safe to cook in here?
- Absolutely.
- When you move, everything
needs to be fastened down
and latched away.
- Pretty much, pretty much.
You're gonna hear some
rattles on the road.
It's okay.
- So I don't know how the RV works.
It's got a water tank,
it's got electricity.
Do we need to charge it like a Tesla?
- The only context I have for RVs
are what I've seen in movies.
Just really worried about
a poop situation happening.
- Okay, fun part.
- [Niki] Is that the poop hole?
- [Garrett] Niki.
- I wanna make sure we get that down.
- You're gonna have sewer
and electricity and water.
The alligator clip.
- [Garrett] There's the
alligator, the matches.
- Put it back on.
Normally, when you pull
up and you'll have a hole
in the ground and stuff like that,
you'll see a rock next to it,
which is there for a reason, all right?
You put this in the hole and then
you just kind of put a rock on top.
- That's not gonna move around.
- What if you don't put the rock on top?
- Don't, don't.
- [David] Nothing.
- That's not what happened
in the Ice Cube movie.
- Given where our relationship is now,
I think spending all this
time together in an RV
will actually push us together.
It is such an obstacle thing,
we have to really work together
to accomplish living
in this motor vehicle.
- With this living situation,
there are too many obstacles.
I think we're gonna be
at each other's throats.
- All right.
- Let's go.
- I'm going back here.
- We basically have to
fasten everything down
while we're driving.
- Oh god.
- You already falling over?
You're just gonna sleep the
whole time I drive, aren't you?
- Yeah.
I'm not a bad driver,
but this thing is so big.
Garrett can drive it.
This is his sized vehicle.
You sure you can drive this thing?
- We're gonna find out.
- We're on our way to the Grand Canyon.
On a scale of one to ten,
how scared are you right now?
- Like an eight.
I don't know how I'm gonna make this turn,
I don't know how I'm gonna make, I don't,
you gotta, I can't see the mirror.
- Oh my god, okay.
- The drive wasn't so bad.
It's a lot of vehicle.
- You won't hit that car.
- I think I will.
- I don't think so.
- Look at you, driving a bus.
- Yes, look at me.
- This is finally a you-sized vehicle.
- Wow, does this feel dangerous.
- [Niki] You're doing a great job.
Keep your eyes on the road.
I'm already tired.
I'm gonna go take a nap in the back.
Ah.
- Am I allowed to be back
here while you're driving?
The people in the car behind
us can definitely see me.
While Garrett was driving this afternoon,
I laid down back here,
but it's a really bumpy ride
so everything just felt super crazy
and everything was shaking.
- [Garrett] I actually was really happy
that Niki was able to lay down and nap
while I was driving, and be comfortable
because then it doesn't feel as cramped.
It doesn't feel as sort of arduous
as a road trip can feel.
At first, I was very
nervous driving this thing,
but then, after just 10 miles,
I was very comfortable doing it.
- We made it, Garrett drove
us to the Grand Canyon.
- Couldn't have done it without
you asleep in the back, Nik.
- It was so bumpy.
It's very dark and I have
no idea where we are.
But now we gotta go hook up the poop hose
so Garrett can poop.
I don't think Garrett's
used the bathroom yet.
I think he's scared.
Welcome to my crib.
There's water, that's for the poop.
- There's that rock he was talking about.
- What do we do first?
- Water and power.
That's where we put the power.
- Which one's 30?
- [Niki] There were a few learning hiccups
about how to hook up this
machine, transformer, bus.
- This is hard.
It goes in both ways and
doesn't turn either way.
Let's do the water.
Hooking it up to the
system was a little weird.
All right, it's accepting it.
- We have water.
- It seems to be leaking pretty,
- [Niki] Do we just leave it?
- [Garrett] Maybe shut
it off for a second.
We had a couple hiccups but
I think that was just because
we'd never done it before.
Now, if we had to hook this thing up
to any place, anywhere in the country,
I think we'd be able
to do it without issue.
- There we go.
We have done it.
RV.
(laughs) You missed.
Garrett and I are really
figuring out each other's quirks,
I think, he eats like a 14-year-old.
All he wants to eat are cheeseburgers.
All right, well this is going great.
- Yeah, it always goes great for you
because you just sit and watch me cook.
- There's no space for me to help you.
Do you want me to stand right next to you
and watch burgers brown?
- Yes.
No, sit down.
Niki and I started getting in
tiny little fights, a little bit.
- He and I can pick on
each other and it's fine.
I'll sit back while he makes dinner
and does all the dishes (laughs).
- [Garrett] It does look pretty good, Nik.
You see? (fire alarm beeps)
Oh, shit.
- [Niki] Just fan it, fan it, don't.
Move, stop, don't, don't.
- Why are you, stop doing it still.
- Ventilation.
- Okay, well now we found
something for you to do.
It's maybe even a sign
of friendship progress
when you can get in little
fights with your friends
and know that that's gonna be fine.
Not that that's a good thing. (laughs)
- [Niki] When I try to
do stuff, he'll be like,
"No, why would you do it that way,
I'll do it," he wants to be in control.
He wants to be in charge, so fine.
- I'm sick of cooking dinner for her.
- So tomorrow we'll get up for sunrise?
- Yeah, tomorrow let's see the sunrise
over the Grand Canyon.
Okay, goodnight, Niki.
- Goodnight.
- Well, it's the morning of the first day.
We're going to miss the
sunrise over the Grand Canyon.
I think this was a pretty
optimistic plan to begin with
'cause I don't think Niki's
ever seen the sunrise.
I'm gonna still try to
get this thing unhooked
so that we can drive around
the Grand Canyon for the day.
Well, we're all unhooked,
ready to see the sunrise over
the Grand Canyon. (laughs)
Looks like it's already pretty risen.
Meanwhile, Niki sleeps.
(relaxing music)
Here I am, near the Grand Canyon.
Wow.
- So it's about 8:30.
I think Garrett drove us somewhere
because we were definitely moving.
I guess he's seeing the
Grand Canyon by himself,
which is kind of frustrating.
I know that I kind of made it
so that our plan fell through.
The least he could have
done would have been,
hey, I'm gonna drive us
across the park, is that cool?
There's no water.
So he decided to do all
of this on his own and
now I'm kind of trapped.
(frustrated grunt)
He's very much used to kind
of doing things on a whim.
It just so happens that him
deciding to do something
by himself also meant
dragging me along in the back
while I was half asleep.
- So you were awake when we were driving?
- Of course.
- And you didn't wanna
ask what we were doing?
- How?
- I don't know.
Saying anything, we're all in one room.
- You could've said, "Hey,
we're gonna go somewhere,
is that cool?"
- You were asleep, I
didn't wanna wake you up.
- So you unilaterally decided to do stuff
without telling me?
- We made a plan to see the Grand Canyon.
Then she didn't wake up.
But I'm trying not to become
defensive about things.
- Fine, let's go.
- Where's my hat?
My hair looks terrible.
Okay.
Behold, the Grand Canyon parking lot.
So you slept pretty good, were you cold?
- No, it was fine.
- Did you use that electric blanket?
- Yeah.
- It's really gonna be bad
if you don't like this thing.
- Why wouldn't I like it?
- I don't know.
Ta da.
- Oh my god, it's huge.
- It's pretty big, isn't it?
- Yeah.
- It's pretty cool.
I don't know how things
are between us now,
like if we've taken a step back
or if we're back to where we were.
I don't think we'll know until tomorrow.
- I was frustrated and I was upset.
I just need a little bit sometimes
and then I can participate
and then I can be involved
and I can be invested, but
Grand Canyon's kind of amazing.
Wow.
- That said, there's really
not much to do but look at it.
(relaxing music)
(sighs)
- All right, eggs.
The kitchen is, I'd say,
not the worst kitchen
we've had to live with.
Wait, turn this to gas?
- Is one lit, is one on gas?
If one's on gas, turn it off.
- They're all off.
I'm starting to understand
a little bit more
why people enjoy RVs and
there's definitely been parts
of this experience that I've enjoyed
but a lot of it's still
very challenging for me.
- Actually, living in this
RV's been a little bit
rockier than I thought it was going to be.
We'll see tomorrow if it's
really brought us together
or actually sort of done
damage to our relationship.
- [Niki] I think I made
the coffee too strong.
- No such thing.
Whoa, that does smell strong.
- That's not what it should taste like.
Next time you decide to drive the van,
can you tell me first?
- I wanted to let you sleep.
- Okay, well when you
drive, I don't sleep.
So just tell me next
time, you can wake me up.
- [Garrett] Okay, sorry
I didn't wake you up.
My knees.
- We should get you a little stool.
Thanks for doing dishes.
- Thanks for drying.
- I don't think either of us knew
the type of relationship
investment we were getting into
when we decided to live
in this RV together.
- Over the course of the
day, though, it got better.
Niki, wanna go for a ride?
Look at her go.
Fun?
- Yeah.
So I have enough room in
this bathroom to do my hair,
which is nice, quarters are
a little tight still, but
I can at least do this.
- Okay, I'm gonna go take a shower.
- Good luck.
- How am I gonna do this?
This is taking some planning.
I forgot to lay out a bath mat.
- We've gotten really good
at connecting the house up
to its inputs, which seemed like something
that we would never get good at.
- There's still a few buttons and stuff
that I don't know how to work,
so I'm very thankful that
Garrett knows how to use them
and work them, 'cause he's
been kind of taking the reins
on being in charge of
functioning the vehicle.
Water, power, TV, RV.
- High five.
- Shall we transform the area?
- You wanna transform it into beds?
- [Niki] Yeah.
Tomorrow we have a lot of work to do
to clean up the RV and to pack
up and to get out of here.
- We are going to refold everything up,
unhook everything, oh,
my nose is bleeding.
Are you still filming this, you fuck?
Morning of the third day,
hopefully Niki will wake
up and make us coffee.
- [Niki] This has been a
very interesting experience.
- [Garrett] Look at it go.
- This is my favorite part of the RV.
I definitely understand
the purpose that it serves
and I totally understand
why there are so many
RVs in this park right now,
but that being said, man,
it's been a challenge.
- This is probably the
most different living style
we've done, it's all in all a small space,
but pretty efficient.
We really had everything
we needed to live.
- It's a transformer.
This feels like something you do
with people that you know
you can piss off to no end
and have them still love
you at the end of the day.
I don't know if we're there yet
and I don't know if this was good for us.
This whole thing rocks when
you walk back and forth.
- This thing?
- [Niki] Yeah, you giant.
- [Garrett] I don't
think this RV brought us
closer together, it almost
pushed us further apart.
- [Niki] It's been a challenge.
I don't know where we go from here.
I think he and I are
really ready to be alone
and to be apart from each other right now.
- I just needed to know
that she's never gonna
wake up for a sunrise, what
am I thinking? (laughs)
the Grand Canyon is breathtaking.
It's unbelievable.
Nothing does it justice
except for going there
and standing on the edge
and being like, oh my god.
You gotta do it, at least once.
You don't have to.
Live your life however you want.
- [Niki] This experience
has been very beautiful.
We're seeing a part of the country
that I've never seen before.
The Grand Canyon's unbelievable,
driving through it's been really fun.
- That said, I wanna get back to my house.
So badly.
- [Niki] Bye.
- Bye RV.
- [Niki] Next week
- [Garrett] On Home Buddies.
- Arcosanti, what is it?
It's almost as if we're
citizens of a new city.
- [Lady] We'll have you work
in construction tomorrow.
- Can I ask how much rent is?
- [Lady] $300 a month.
- Wow.
I don't think Niki's going to like this.
- I'm getting some pod share vibes.
- I'm really afraid that
at the end of three days
I'm not gonna know what this was.